problem number one at time t a particle
moving in the x y plane is at position x
of t y of t where x of t and y of t are
not explicitly given for t is greater
than or equal to zero the derivative of
x with respect to t is four t plus one
the derivative of y with respect to t
is sine of t squared and at time t
equals zero x of zero is zero and y of
zero is negative four fair enough let's
do part a
find the speed of the particle at time t
equals three and find the acceleration
vector of the particle at time t is
equal to three as well
so the speed is really just the
magnitude of the velocity
vector so what's the velocity vector our
velocity vector as a function of time is
going to be equal to
our
the derivative of our x position as a
function of time or we could say the
velocity in the x direction times the i
unit vector plus the velocity in the y
direction
times the j unit vector i just wrote
this in engineering notation obviously
there are many ways that you could
specify a vector and in this case x
prime of t they've already given it to
us x prime of t is four t plus one i
just they just wrote it as dx dt so this
over here is four t
plus one
times the i unit vector and then this
here this y prime of t they gave it to
us the derivative of y with respect to t
is sine of t squared so plus
sine of t squared
plus sine of t squared times the j unit
vector that is
our velocity vector so what is our
velocity or this is this is our velocity
vector as a function of time so what is
our velocity vector at time t equals 3
well we just have to substitute 3 for t
so 4 times 3 plus 1 is 13 i
plus
3 squared 3 squared is 9 sine of 9 plus
sine
of nine j
our speed what they what they want us to
figure out is going to be equal to
is going to be equal to or maybe i
should write it as our speed at time
three
our speed is going to be equal to the
magnitude of our velocity vector at time
3 which is equal to the magnitude of
13 i plus sine
of 9
j
and then this we literally this is we
use essentially the pythagorean theorem
to find the magnitude this is going to
be equal to the square root
square root of 169 that's 13 squared
plus
sine of 9
sine of 9 squares let me get my
ti-85 out
this part of the exam we are allowed to
use calculators so we get the square
root
of
169
plus
the square root of 169 plus
sine of 9
sine of 9 squared
all right that's 13 squared plus sine of
9 squared
and we get
we get
13.00 i'll just round it to 7 just to
show that we didn't get just straight up
13 that the sine of 9 squared did do
something so 13.00
so this is approximately equal to
13.007 so we've answered the first part
the speed of the particle at time 3
equals 0 is 13.007
then they want us to find the
acceleration vector of the particle at
time t equals 3. so the acceleration
vector is a function of time the
acceleration vector as a function of
time is just going to be the second
derivative of x with respect to t or you
say the acceleration in the x direction
as a function of time times i plus the
acceleration in the y direction so it's
the second derivative of y with respect
to t
in
the j direction and this of course is
just going to be equal to
the derivative of x of the derivative of
x the second derivative of x of t is
just the derivative of the first
derivative
so the first derivative is four t plus
one you take the derivative of that you
just get four so we get four
i plus
and then the derivative the second
derivative or the second derivative of y
with respect to t is just the derivative
of the first derivative the derivative
the first derivative is sine of t
squared so derivative of that is going
to be 2t
times
times cosine
of t squared and of course we have our j
we have our j right over there and i
just did this from the chain rule the
derivative of t the derivative of t
squared with respect to t is 2t
derivative of sine of t squared with
respect to t squared is cosine of t
squared and so that is the acceleration
vector as a function of t but they care
at time t is equal to three
so
four still stays four then you have two
times three plus cosine of nine so let
me write this it's going to be
so our acceleration vector our
acceleration vector at time 3 is going
to be 4 i
4 i
plus and let's just put if this is this
is 2 times 3 which is 6
times cosine
6 times cosine of 9
j
let's get the calculator out so we
actually get a value there since
they allow us to use or almost want us
to use the calculator here so 6 times
cosine
of 9
6 times cosine of 9 is negative 5.47
or 5.467 if we want so plus
negative
oh what was i doing this is j so plus
negative 5.46
j so that is our acceleration vector and
once again i wrote it in engineering
notation which i'm sure the the advanced
placement exam people wouldn't mind but
you could also write it in kind of in
kind of your the
parameterized vector notation or your
ordered pair notation as a vector you
could say that the vector the
acceleration vector times three you
could write it this way too for
negative
5.467 these are really specifying the
same thing this is the x component of
the vector this is the y component of
the vector this is the x component of
the vector this is the y component of
the vector